quel d'art car c'était énorme on a pu
voir que les naturistes ils font tout
comme tout le monde un moment il joue au
bowling bah oui mais c'est réglé
elle joue bowling café du naturisme à
part vous haut et de haut niveau moi
j'ai été très bon il ya des étoiles
vaduz et mes toiles tonna tourisme non
mais j'ai été bon et je faisais les
courges bien sûr on fait tous voila
comme un coma
franchement je respecte mais ils vont
dans un restaurant au moment il n'y a
que des naturistes et tout moi manger
avec une top à côté ça va c'est bon pas
aujourd'hui non mais des fois les
balades singes et parlent de thomson
réveil pour une fois je tiens naturiste
je vais sa marge et comment tu faisais
si tout bénéfice jolie pour pas lui
montrer
bah oui c'est une vraie question non
mais mutation ça vient pas par ici sa
raideur le z
non mais c'est une vraie question est en
fait le fait d'être en public fait que
tu n'as pas d'érection exactement à lui
le public le rouge regardez 116 plage
dédié à cette pratique dans l'hexagone
le naturisme
comptant aujourd'hui sortir des lieux où
il est confiné
fait une démonstration pour dire quelle
position à la lettre
[Musique]
la grenouille
sympa dans la naturisme cas sympa dans
nature insee c'est une doctrine qui
prône le retour à la nature dès que ça
c'est sympa oui ça c'est bien c'est
louable mais moi particulièrement n'eut
jamais preuve parce que je suis passé
bien crise il est ce que vous aviez fait
du naturisme a pas du tout et ça ne
risque pas du tout au privé en prix mais
je suis français mais en privé oui non
mais je vais dire qu'elle prend sa
douche en doudoune et moi ce que je
regrette quand même quand je regarde des
émissions comme celle ci c'est qu'il
n'ya pas de super beaux gosses quoi il
n'ya pas de super beaux corps y en a
beaucoup en général ils sont pas très
jeunes ils sont pas très beaux ils sont
pas de mignolet du naturisme avec
quelqu'un s'il n'y en a même pas en rêve
même avait quand même avec moi je
regarde moi je fais partie de la grande
majorité silencieuse qui ne va jamais se
risquer à vous
non pas du tout et ça fait quand je le
voit assis dans le sable avec tout je
pense à tous les grains dans les rouages
là est-ce que ça doit vous avez déjà
fait l'amour sur la plage
oui mais bien justement parlons-en
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous vois tu te régales quand même tu
as l'air des lampions exceptionnel ça je
sais que dans le foin dans le sable et
tout ça vous dire c'est beau cinéma
parce que dans la réalité bonjour vous
avez vérité un fois elle avait été
héritée du tram et théo descoings ce
derby des deux camps parce que toutes
les gaines le samedi où le printemps
arabe de palliatifs mais sinon pour le
reste c'est un désastre les fesses de
babouins merci